here's to four to eight years of  pre-gaming with dead we have to do  something spooky how about light as a  feather stiff as a board  I know a way that's different happy  Halloween is everybody set for dates for  my party Saturday  I know it's hard starting over violets  new here and she doesn't have any  friends  maybe that's for a reason I'm sorry  inclusion is apart too  let's invite her here's to best friends  she had everything a girl could want  seriously messed up she knew exactly how  our free was gonna die from now on we  need to watch her left  [Music]  [Applause]  there's something seriously wrong with  that  this theme came from some distant  darkness  why does  the game is cursed  Jared of tune  she's dying she's dying  she's dead so who wants to go next  [Music]  you